Another kind of coverage that we might look for is going to be inspired by what happened
after we fix this x fer function and so the likely fixed for the bug that we had in this x fer function
is to lock both of the bank accounts that we're processing, transfer
the balance between them, and then unlock the accounts.
And what this will do is make sure that no other threads in the system are messing
with the two accounts that we're updating while in the middle of the messing with them.
Now one thing that people are found is while testing this concurrent software.
If this often the case, you can delete all of the locks out of a code,
run it through some tests, and often it passes.
This is really a sort of a scary and depressing thing because what this means is that
during the test suite the locks weren't doing anything.
This is in spite of the test coverage metric called synchronization coverage.
What synchronization coverage is going to do is ensure that
during testing this lock actually does something.
In other words, during testing, the x fer function is going to be called to transfer
money between accounts when the accounts are already locked and what this does is ensure that
we're stressing the system to a level that the synchronization code is actually firing.
It's actually having some effect on the execution and if that's happening what that means is
we're probably doing a reasonable job stress testing the system.
So that was really quick and like I said we're not getting into some detail.
In summary, if we're testing concurrent software, we want to be looking at
concurrency-specific coverage metrics such as interleaving coverage which meant
if you recall functions which accessed shared data are actually called and in a truly
concurrent fashion that is by multiple threads at the same time.
And also synchronization coverage which ensures
that the locks that we put into our code actually do something.